one of those players who is subject to
the july 15 deadline for a long-term
deal chief's defensive lineman chris
jones
said on social media on tuesday
basically
if i don't get a long-term deal i'm not
signing the tender and i'm going to sit
out the season
i've spoken to le'veon bell
bell is the guy who sat on the 2018
season now
there's a difference in sitting out all
of the second season of the franchise
tender versus the first season of the
franchise tender if chris jones sits out
all of this season he can still be
tagged next year at a 20 increase over
what the tag was this year if you sit
out all of the second year
of the franchise tag the following year
the only way to retain the players
rights via the franchise tag is to give
him that quarterback offer the five
highest cap numbers in the league the
average of those cap numbers becomes the
franchise tender for that third season
something that no one is ever going to
do with a non-quarterback most likely
there may be some exception at some
point some transcendent player who just
gets a sack on every play or something
along those lines for the most part
though teams aren't going to use the
third franchise tender on anyone but a
quarterback and even on a quarterback
you're looking at a 44 bump over the
second tag so long story bearable if
you're gonna sit out the full season
it's better to do it in the second year
of the tag now chris jones needs to
remember a couple of things first of all
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
world right now one thing that is
certain is that offer that has been put
on the table and the promise of a 20
raise next year even if the salary cap
goes down 20 raised next year the only
way he doesn't get the 20 raise next
year is if there's some sort of
agreement between the league and the
union where the union for all franchise
tag players says well it won't be a 20
bump
in 2021 it'll be 10 or 15 or 5 or
something else that's the only way
that that goes away is if the
fundamental rules of the franchise tag
change
and i'm not suggesting they will i'm
just using that as an example of how it
could happen if there is some
negotiation over
the broader issues that are involved in
this effort to try to figure out how to
play during a pandemic and if there is
an agreement reached on how to deal with
a reduced franchise tag or salary cap
for next year that's a possibility
possibility not a probability
anyway at a time when there is so much
that is
impossible to figure out the smart move
would be to go ahead and take that
franchise tag play it out this year take
the 20 raise next year and then if you
have to go year to year for two seasons
after that second year
it's going to be very difficult for the
chiefs to use the franchise tag
a third time the most they would do is
transition tag a third time which would
be a 20 raise over
the second year franchise tag salary
which again would be a 20 bump over this
year the numbers go up very quickly so i
know chris jones wants that long-term
deal this isn't an ideal climate to get
a long-term deal and frankly you know
you got to make your decisions in light
of what the climate is the climate
suggests going year to year go year to
year it's still damn good money at a
time when many things are uncertain
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports